this morning another american city is
rocked by outrage over the police
shooting of a black man
it was all caught on video angry
protests led to an overnight curfew in
kenosha wisconsin that's between
milwaukee and chicago
the man who was shot 29-year-old jacob
blake is now in a milwaukee hospital
our national correspondent jerica duncan
has more on this story and we have to
tell you ahead of time this video
very tough to watch this graphic video
posted on facebook shows the moment an
encounter between jacob blake and
kenosha police
quickly escalated screams rang out as
police fired at least seven
shots sunday evening blake appears to
have been shot in the back
as he entered the driver's side of an
suv at gunpoint
his children were reportedly in the
vehicle it is unclear whether police
believe they saw a weapon
i know he got a kids and girl and all
that and
i never had a problem with him i always
see him every day parks right behind me
on the street
local reports suggest blake was breaking
up a fight between
two women when the police were called
that part of the incident was
not caught on camera a large number of
protesters confronted officers in
kenosha sunday night
in addition to peaceful demonstrations
at least one police officer
was reportedly attacked when protests
turned ugly elsewhere
a county-wide curfew was put in place
overnight
wisconsin governor tony evers released a
statement saying
we stand with all those who have and
continue to demand
justice equity and accountability for
black lives in our country
zach rodriguez a board supervisor in
kenosha county
said this incident highlights the need
for more widespread use of recording
devices by police
what happened here tonight highlights
that that we
need body cameras for not just our
sheriff's deputies but our city police
department as well
one person who says they're a member of
the local black lives matter chapter
says the video
is just the latest in a long line of
events of police brutality
against black americans we're tired of
it
and right now this is the wrong
generation that this is happening to
the frustration is boiling to the top
and we're sick and tired
that was jerica duncan reporting very
distressing
he's right we are sick and tired it's
the thing anthony that even if he had a
gun and it's not clear to anyone that he
did
he's still shot in the back as he's
getting in the car
in the car and you see the woman who's
jumping outside there are children in
the car her children are in the cars
we're all watching this
thank goodness for the videotape so that
we can continue
justice in this story that's very
disturbing to see there was body there
were body cameras as well on the cops
though